hacer esto lo que salva el planeta
tierra la nasa deposita todas sus
esperanzas en este tipo de tecnología
con el fin de salvar a las generaciones
futuras de eventuales impactos de
asteroides la nave d'art acrónimo de
prueba de redireccionamiento de doble
asteroide se precipitara hacia dy
morphos una pequeña luna que orbita
alrededor de un asteroide llamado
dídimos su misión es desviarlo de su
curso chocando contra el a máxima
velocidad
nuestra misión es chocar contra un
asteroide a 25.000 kilómetros por hora
un impacto fuerte y difícil
hemos trabajado mucho en el diseño de
una misión que golpeará a la luna de un
sistema de asteroides los científicos
estudiarán el cambio de la trayectoria
del objeto con el impacto lo harán
midiendo cuánto tiempo tarda la luna en
órbita del asteroide después del choque
el objetivo es averiguar si este tipo de
tecnología será suficiente para
redirigir asteroides en el futuro por
ahora los científicos insisten en que la
tierra no está amenazada francois
off-road y francamente de todos los
objetos cercanos a la tierra que
conocemos hoy ninguno de ellos
representa una amenaza dentro de 100
años aproximadamente
actualmente la nasa rastrea más de 27
mil asteroides